hello i'm getify but most of you know me
as kyle simpson
and i'm director of web futures for my
own company which means i get to spend
my time envisioning the future of the
web
and empowering others to achieve that to
that end i've also recently partnered
with a company called
tab9 they make an ai powered
autocomplete plugin for your code editor
whichever one your favorite one is that
helps figure out what your code is doing
and make better
semantic suggestions based upon being
trained on open source code
out in the wild as well as figuring out
what you're doing in your own code base
it's a really exciting and opening up
space and i'm
really looking forward to seeing more
coming there so keep an eye on tab nine
and you'll hear more from me about that
in the future
today we're going to talk about monads
and i know that's some really scary
stuff
in the overall realm of functional
programming it definitely can be a bit
scary
in addition to some other books that you
may know that i've written
you probably haven't heard or don't know
about the functional light javascript
book
now functionality javascript is all
about functional programming but it has
an appendix in there about monads
so obviously i think you should read the
whole book but especially
check out that appendix if you want more
information about what we're talking
about today
so we only have a few minutes to speak
here together
and the topic of monads is such a big
and complex
and kind of intimidating topic so don't
expect for this to be like a phd
dissertation or anything like that
we're just going to try to develop some
ground up intuition
about how these things help us solve
problems in our code
so don't worry if it feels like it's
going too quick this is to just get your
feet wet
and then i hope that you'll look into
some libraries and some other writings
on the topic if you want to learn more
this quote some people have
purposed this quote in many different
ways you can fill in the blank with
different things besides regular
expressions uh so we filled in the blank
with lot with lots of different things
before
but especially i think we hear this a
lot with regular expressions
and to be honest with you it's entirely
fair that you may think that what i'm
about to do today
is the same thing i'm suggesting that we
have these problems in our programs and
when i suggest moan ads
that might feel like we're just creating
more problems but i do hope
that you'll keep an open mind about it
because the truth is that
actually regular expressions have kind
of gotten a bad rap
i mean regular expressions have been
used for lots of really
important and useful tasks and and so i
think they're really good and
actually all developers really should
learn to use them in their programs
but let's be honest what we've all heard
or seen or maybe even attempted
ourselves
is to parse some arbitrary block of html
text with a regular expression
and then we quickly realize what just a
terrible idea that is
if you were parsing just a small piece
of html that you knew the structure of
it
a regular expression is perfectly
reasonable but if you're trying to parse
any arbitrary text that might be
formatted like html
well then things just get completely out
of hand so
you've probably heard this adage before
about the right tool for the right job
but there's more to it than just the
right tool because we also have to use
the tool in the way that it was designed
so imagine if i my task is to put a nail
into the wall
and i have a hammer in my hand that's
the right tool and if i swing
the hammer it's going to work probably
pretty well i mean i'm decent with a
hammer
but if i were to stick that hammer in my
mouth and try to swing it
it's not going to work even though it's
the right tool for the right job if it's
not used
in the right way so what we're getting
at here is that
a task like parsing all arbitrary html
is not the right task for regular
expressions it's not the right tool and
it's not the right usage of the
tool but for a very specific task
well absolutely that can be the right
the right tool for that job
so really it's the question of
specialized tasks versus generalized
trask
and and i would argue the same is true
of monads
as i'm saying here about regular
expressions now i love this quote
because what really stands out to me
about this quote
is the yet part it's that we we have to
embrace the
idea that all of technology and as we're
talking today about software
that software is an ever evolving
process that it's just
a moment in time so what you're seeing
in this talk today is actually just a
moment in time of my journey to learn
functional programming and to learn moan
ads
and that doesn't represent the end it's
not the beginning it's not the end it's
somewhere in the middle we're all
in progress and so all software is kind
of like that as well it's not a finished
working product
but we're on the way to it and that's
why i want to share these thoughts today
so let's take a look at monads let's
start to break down this topic a little
bit and how might we want to define or
explain monads well a typical functional
programmer might
cite some of this kind of haskell type
theory notation stuff
which literally is greek to me i don't
understand
what many of those symbols mean and so
that doesn't really do a lot for me
you may have also heard them referred to
as
burritos or onions or other sorts of
silly metaphors but
i want to share with you the one that i
prefer the most
because i like to think of a monad as i
do
other things in programming as like a
rubik's cube meaning that there are
different
sides to it and we can look at one side
and understand one aspect of it
without having to completely understand
the entire cube
and that's sort of what we're going to
do today is look at one side
of how monads are to develop some
intuition from the ground up about
things we already do in our programs
and how we want to use monads to solve
those maybe in better ways
but that's not the same thing as
completely fully understanding
everything there is to know about a
monad but to answer that
really important question that i know is
all in the back of your mind but
but what is a monad well let me just
define
it this way it's a set of rules for how
one collection of
one or more values and behaviors can
interact with another collection of
values or behaviors and if you sort of
squint it at that
you might call that a data structure now
i know that's a bad word especially
because there's a lot of connotation to
data structure from the object-oriented
world for example we think about data
structures as
data and behavior but we think about the
methods as modifying that state
and in a monad it's going to hold on to
whatever information it has
and that's not ever going to change we
might produce a new thing out of it so
it's a little bit like
maybe an immutable data structure but
even that's not exactly correct
so i do understand why sometimes people
ruffle a little bit
at this idea of calling it a data
structure but i think in terms of
developing some intuition i think that's
an okay place to start
to think about it as that's what we do
in our programs when we have this value
and we want to give it some specific
behavior we wrap it up and we can do
that with
a data structure a formal class in
object-oriented programming
but we can do it with monads when we're
approaching
functional programming so ultimately i
find this what question
a bit of a distraction to become
completely honest
yes there's a lot of formality behind it
but what i really want us to focus our
attention on is actually the why
i want us to ask why monad's more than
just what monads i think
that is a more important question so you
all have probably heard
this quote before or seen it quoted in
some place if you've ever been to
another monad talk there's
at least a decent chance that this has
been quoted at some point as a matter of
fact i used to use this phrase
i used to quote this as sort of a way to
kind of put push back on or critique the
functional programming space
because you can hear these things cited
and they're using all these
kind of strange words like monad and
monoid and
category and endo function what are all
these weird words and
and and the the word just there kind of
implies that it should be self-obvious
now the the true etymology of this
phrase was actually used as a joke but
it's been misused
and misapplied and and actually creates
a little bit of a divisive nature where
if
if that statement is not obvious to you
then you probably feel like oh i guess
i'm not smart enough i'm not qualified
enough
to learn these things and that was
absolutely the case for me that
the times that i heard decided over the
years when i was trying to learn
this had nothing but putting me off it
pushed me off
and so i just i want to actually share
in the spirit of that like we're in a
journey
where this used to be just a confusing
jumble of words i just want to quickly
give you a glimpse
that as i've learned more about this
monad space
these words are not completely
meaningless and abstract
they do have actual concrete meanings
that doesn't mean that i think you need
to learn the terms to be able to
understand and use monads
but once you get to know monads better
you will begin to run across these words
more often
so let me give you an example the mona
the monoid we're defining monad in types
of these
in terms of these other words and the
monoid what is a monoid well
it's an associative concat and i know
that's like
defining that weird word with maybe some
other things um
another way of saying it is it's a semi
group or a concatable
but it's it's that idea plus an empty
value and
and though that's going to seem a little
bit confusing and strange to you let me
just break it down with an example
an example for example strings we know
how strings work and we know that
strings can be
concatened together and we know that
there's also an empty string that if you
can count that to any string
it doesn't change the string so you
might have some intuition about how
strings concatenate and how that works
and that there's some associativity
involved in the
in the way that we group the
concatenation of multiple strings
and actually that's just an example of
the formality
that we're talking about with monoid
okay so there's a formal word
for something that you might already
have a bit of intuition about
functor for example functor is a value
or a set of values that can be
mapped over and it results in a new
value or
collection of values of that same type
so for example an array we know arrays
are like a list of numbers or a list of
strings or any other values
and we know that we have the map method
on arrays and so we can call map and we
get back
a new array well actually that's an
example of functor
okay now endo of course is this forest
moon in the star wars galaxy i'm kidding
that's endor endo which actually is
it's kind of comes from words like we
you may have heard of endoscopy which is
like internal surgery through like
little microscopic tubes and stuff like
that
as a prefix endo just means within and
as it's applied here in this space it
really means that a functor
is going to map its values back to the
same category as it started with
which is actually all were already true
of all the monads that we use in
functional programming
so if we break these scary words down it
turns out that there's some intuition
here
that's not too bad it's not too
difficult and as you run across
these things more i don't want you to be
scared by these terms the way that i
used to be
now i just used a bunch of big words and
a bunch of confusing kind of stuff
did you know that there were even such a
thing as multiple algebras because that
was
strange and weird to me this is like
toto i don't think we're in kansas
anymore sort of stuff
but instead of being direct distracted
by that whole what stuff all the
formality of that i just presented it
because i don't want you to be scared by
it
but instead of being distracted by oh i
don't know these words or i don't know
all of these
ideas i want us to focus on that why
part
and that's what this talk is going to
focus on what can we do with these kin
things in our code and why will that
matter
now i have to say one more word about
the space that i'm entering into because
by diving into this talk i know that
people are going to come out of the
woodwork and say oh well actually
because there's probably going to be
something that i'm not exactly formal or
exactly
specific or correct on and so there's
going to be a lot of temptation to do
that and
especially in the functional programming
space there's this idea that there's
kind of
only one way to describe something it's
sort of like the functional programming
police don't want you to explain
anything unless you do it in the one
right way and i just
reject the notion that there's only one
right way to explain monads
i think there's lots of different ways
there's lots of different sides
to that rubik's cube so the way that i'm
going to break this down to try to move
from that formality back to some
informality and some intuition is to
take a bunch of really complex topics
and boil them down into two specific
buckets
we'll call those buckets types and
values
so what are we talking about with types
and values well
we could say that types are the
behaviors that we can expect
for example if you have a number type
that tells us that
things that are numbers we can do math
on them
but that's very abstract that's not
concrete we can't do anything with that
so
you would need a concrete number value
to be able to use it to do math like the
number 42
we needed as an actual thing to do math
on so in javascript land we could see
that types and values are really kind of
blurred they're sort of mixed together
you can be more formal about it and it's
not to say that there aren't types
versus values
but in javascript we do end up kind of
mixing these things together and i think
that's okay
i don't think that we have to be super
formal like oh well that's only the type
thing or that's only a value thing
so as we go throughout this i'll
identify type versus value
but understand that there's quite a bit
of bleed over in the way that we're
presenting it
so what does the what does a monad mean
what does that word
mean it goes back to v
like the type versus a so we want to ask
the question
are we talking about the monad which is
kind of like a type based description
versus
a mona which is a concrete value in our
programs that we could do something with
and one way of defining the monad is
through the formalism of the three laws
and if you've done any reading about
monads you've probably heard of these
three laws
but then we have a monad which as i said
before is kind of like a data structure
that we can actually do something with
in our programs
so a monad will actually have a method
on it like
chain or bind but the monad the laws
they describe
what those kinds of things need to be
able to do they're not going to say it
has to have a chain method but they're
going to say it has to be able to do
the following things so we're describing
it in the more abstract sense with the
type
or we're actually dealing concretely
with something in a program
that we can compute values with oh and
by the way with our values especially in
javascript we can kind of mix these
things together
and we can augment the behaviors and we
can get new and more powerful kinds of
monads like the maybe and the either the
io the reader
and we'll talk about many of these as we
go through the rest of the talk
so i think we need to see some code
because it's been almost 15 minutes of
me talking very abstractly about the
topic
so i'm going to present to you this code
which is using a monad library that i
wrote
now i'm not showing you this library
because i'm it's like a sales job like i
want you to use this library
it's called moneo but i wanted to have
something concrete some actual code that
we could look at and evaluate
and from this talk if you're curious to
play around with monads you might grab
meneo
and play around with it there are many
other monad libraries out there but i
found them to be hard to get started
with
because they sort of focus more on the
formalism for example there are these
monad libraries in what we call the
fantasyland
kind of uh space where where things are
all kind of agreeing a certain way to
work
but there's a lot of formalism around
that when you try to read through some
of the documentation there
i found it to be very difficult a bit
intimidating so
with moneo it's trying to lead with
something a little bit more intuitive
the way we might
try to do something in our javascript
programs more naturally
so what you see here is that we see just
on line one
just is really a actual function that we
can call
you can see that i can pass in the
number three into just
and i can get back another thing right i
can get back this
thing which is a which is an actual a
monad it's a monad instance
and i can call inspect on that thing and
we see that it's a just draft around the
value three
and then i can even ask about some value
and say is this thing
adjust a quick call out is that the just
monad that i've presented here
typically you don't see that as its own
standalone monad in most other libraries
you won't find a thing called just
you'll find that as part of a bigger
mona which is called maybe that we're
going to look at in just a moment
but with moneo i found it to be kind of
more
easier to explain and easier to kind of
it's more convenient if we just
expose it directly as a monad that you
can create it's sort of serving the
purpose of the identity moana here it's
just holding on to a value
but it's making that value be monetic in
its behavior
which makes it easier to interact with
the other monads
all right so we talked about that type
idea and let's just dive into that but
illustrate it with some concrete code
the type or the interface as i said it
doesn't require
a chain method but the implementation in
moneo does
provide that behavior by way of a method
called chain
so we can call a dot chain on it instead
of
for example calling it bind or flat map
and there are aliases to those by the
way but
we chose to go with chain that's my
preferred method name for that
it's the underlying behavior that the
laws require and so what you see here
is a representation of those laws being
proved
for one specific value and for one
specific kind of monad
that's not like proving all monads or
all you know all implementations of the
law
but it does illustrate the ideas behind
the laws and show that if we have
something in code we can prove to
ourselves
that we have a lawful implementation of
a monad and that's really what this code
is doing
it illustrates these monad law derived
behaviors for one specific monad the
just and
for one specific value which is three
so what are these other behaviors that
i've kind of referred to
well we can actually mix these things
together and so
i like to refer to this as monads and
friends it's kind of
my umbrella term for it because we have
monads and we have these other things
that aren't strictly monads
but i often pair them together i see
them most useful when paired together so
i already mentioned the semi group or
the concatable but there's also
foldable and applicative and some of
these others in the space
and category theory tells us that these
exist completely independently
but i as i said in practice i often see
them
most useful when they are mixed together
so i'm going to kind of lump them
together informally under this
umbrella term of monads and friends and
that's how we're going to go about
our exploration today is looking at how
we work with monads and their friends to
get
problem solved in our programs so let's
just take a quick example
foldable is one of the behaviors that we
can associate or kind of mix in with our
monads it's not
strictly a monad behavior but it's
something that we can mix in and so i'm
going to show you a usage of
a monitor i've already referred to which
is called the maybe monet
and we're actually going to come back
and look more at maybe in just a little
bit but
just just a quick glimpse of how maybe
works and i want to call out
that this fold method that we have here
that is the foldable behavior
added into or mixed into our maybe
implementation in the mineo library
so what it's doing here actually is it's
saying inside of this maybe i either
have an actual affirmative value or i
basically have an emptiness
it's one of the two and the fold method
says if i have one or the other of these
things
pick whichever one it is and invoke one
of the functions
either from line five or from line six
invoke one of those functions depending
upon what kind of value i have
if i have no value at all like it's the
empty value then invoke the function
from line five
which as you see is sort of providing a
default fallback here that dash dash but
if i have a real
actual value held inside of my maybe
monad then the fold method will invoke
the second one the one from line six in
which case you can see that i'm actually
formatting that currency to look like
u.s currency
so the maybe is allowing us to hold on
to a value and then
the foldable allows us to make a
decision on that value
whether we want to kind of fall back to
a default or do
some other operations so there's our
monads and friends they're working
together they're playing well
in the sandbox if you will so we're
going to come back to maybe in just a
moment
i just wanted to kind of put that little
example out there so it didn't feel
quite so abstract
okay so i have mentioned this a couple
of times and i want to give you a more
straightforward answer why monets
and i'm going to say that the answer
that i think best to that
is because they are a tool just like
regular expressions
that if you have a problem and if you
find the right tool
and the right way to use that tool you
can more effectively solve the problem
there's lots of things that you can do
with a hammer not all of them are the
right thing to do with a hammer and
there's
one right way or a couple of right ways
to use a hammer and a bunch of ways you
could use it incorrectly
so they have these monads they happen to
model and solve problems a bit
differently than we're used to and
that's going to
look very unfamiliar to us and that's
going to feel scary and feel less
readable
but i just want to say that if you use
these things incorrectly
you absolutely will go off you know off
the rails
but if you use them correctly in the
same way that if you use regular
expressions correctly they can be a very
powerful tool
that unlocks even more capabilities in
our programs and monads are definitely
that way if we use them correctly
they really do unlock a lot of power in
our programs so they can be very helpful
if we use them correctly okay so what
problems might we
face in our programs like what kind of
questions
might we ask we could say how could i
for example choose a value or a fallback
or how could i gracefully handle an
exception or how could i handle these
side effects that happen
in my program these are all things that
you already handle
in all of your programs and you already
that means you already have solutions to
them
which is completely okay all right i'm
not saying that any of the
existing solutions that you have are
insufficient you have shipped
great applications with solutions to
these that you've never used monads
before
but you might not have ever stopped to
wonder is there a better way of solving
that same problem we know that every
problem could probably be solved
a hundred different ways but is there a
better way to solve that problem
and what i want us to get a glimpse of
is how might we do it
if we were going to use monads now
beware
that these particular solutions are
going to look very different
and much less familiar and as our
instinct
always is when something looks less
familiar we immediately jump to the
conclusion
that thing is less readable i could
never understand it i could never use it
and more importantly
nobody else on my team would ever accept
that kind of code
and the problem that we have here is
that familiarity
is the most key ingredient to
readability and so the catch-22 is if
you don't ever push your envelope and
try new things
you'll never get more familiar with them
and then there will be more readable
the same was true when you were on some
older javascript framework and then you
decided to switch to react
the first few days it looked very very
different to you
and it was probably a lot less readable
and then over time you got more familiar
with it and now it's probably very
readable
or you know substitute view or angular
or whatever your favorite framework
might be
so what i'm suggesting here is that the
tension the catch-22
is that you do kind of have to push that
envelope a little bit you do have to
work
on these things you can't just assume
that you will always
immediately glance at it and understand
what it's doing
and by the way tasks one and two here
they illustrate the
we're going to use them with the maybe
and the either monads respectively
but actually they're sort of
interchangeable and that's going to be
kind of an interesting thing
we're going to use maybe for task one
but you could actually do maybe for task
two
and we'll use either for two but you
could do that with task one
it's kind of an interesting
characteristic of these that sometimes
we can swap in a different tool and
still get the job done
once we learn the in insides the ins and
outs of how these things work
and i also want to call out that this is
just three right because i only have a
few minutes more to speak with you
there's lots and lots of other problems
that we solve and monads can solve many
many of those other problems
so i don't mean for this to be like an
exhaustive list it was just kind of like
the three quick ones
that i thought i could illustrate best
for us all right so
i want us to jump in let's look at that
first one choosing a value or a fallback
now i want you to look here at this um
this implementation i'm using the maybe
as i said and i want you to look here on
that first line you see maybe.from okay
see maybe.from is taking some value and
it's putting it into a maybe and it's
making a decision
it may not seem obvious to you but it's
making a decision is this value
present and available or is it one of
those like empty values like null or
undefined
so when we get a maybe value we've made
a decision
of representing it as a maybe just as
you can see there on line three
or representing it as a maybe nothing
which is what we're illustrating on line
six
on line six we do the maybe dot from
with null and then we end up with this
maybe nothing value
okay the the maybe function that we see
on line eight
is the unit constructor it's not the
same thing as maybe.from
and that's a little subtle difference
but the unit constructor is just going
to
wrap a maybe around whatever you give it
like a maybe just around whatever you
give it it's not going to make the
decisions
that is it empty or not the maybe.from
helper utility is the thing that's
making those decisions
and the only reason i call that out is
if you google implementations of monads
you're going to find
a bunch of examples of people making
moan ads writing blog posts about monads
and they almost always do maybe
and they almost always do this
illustration of maybe
where they take the unit constructor and
they put that
logic of deciding undefined or not into
that unit constructor and that's
actually a no-no
because it turns out that it makes the
unit constructor invalid according to
the law
the laws of monads they sort of cheat
because it's a little bit more
convenient
and so i i just want to show you that we
are calling out very specifically
that that our helper utility maybe.from
is where that selection logic can happen
so an example from some real code this
is an application
that i've actually been working on and i
wanted to give us an example of some
real code
that i was writing and i was doing it in
a very imperative
non-functional non-monotic way and then
i got to thinking well this would be a
good way of trying to illustrate
kind of side by side how we might do
something monotonically so you see here
that i'm i'm basically doing
a regular expression match there's our
good friend regular expression again
i'm doing a regular expression match
against these mime types that come from
like a drop down
in the app and what i'm basically
pulling out is if it matches this video
audio or image
then i want to use it and if it doesn't
match then it's going to end up
basically just defaulting to this
web value so that's what you see here is
that we're doing a destructuring
assignment against the match value
we're doing that not equals null check
that's the important thing there
that not equals null check is is what
we're
we're deciding do i have a real value or
do i need to substitute this
backup value like quote web okay and
you probably recognize code like this
you maybe didn't use ternaries maybe you
did if statements but you've probably
done logic like this in your programs
where you've needed to select one value
or select another fallback value
so that's all i'm doing here and it's
just three or four short lines of code
so it's not that complex
but i wanted to let's take this as an
opportunity to illustrate how we might
do it
with monads so here's what we're going
to do the same exact
outcome what we're going to do with
monads and the way we're going to do it
is
again we still do the regular expression
on line two but on line three
we're going to throw that value that we
got into the maybe by
by way of that utility that maybe.from
because that's where that little
not equals null check is gonna happen
inside of there
and then we're going to call our good
friend fold that's the foldable behavior
that's mixed in with maybe
fold is going to allow us to make a
decision basically do i have one of
those maybe empties in which case i want
to fall back to the web
otherwise i have a maybe just around
some specific match value
and then i just want to grab it out and
here you see i just kind of do the no op
with the identity function
just takes it returns back whatever it
took in
so the fold along with that maybe.from
is doing that
selection logic that we did imperatively
with the ternary in the previous
and again this is a little bit more
verbose and certainly less familiar to
you so your instinct might be oh this is
not less
this is less readable i don't want to do
it and you may be ready to tune me out
but what i hope that you'll hear from me
is that
actually there's a lot more power in
representing this solution
through monads it unlocks all of these
other capabilities which are not super
obvious in this one little kind of
isolated example so as we go along i
hope that you're just getting an
intuition
that you can solve problems this way
that it's not completely outlandish
but it's okay if it still feels less
familiar
that's kind of the point it is going to
be less familiar but it's going to push
the envelope forward in our programs
we're going to evolve and
be able to write better software as a
result
okay so one last example maybe
not actually last example but another
example that's maybe a little bit more
in depth
for this maybe monad we're still doing
that same not equals null check
but what i wanted to do here was also be
able to
do a little bit of logic after the
selection check so as you see there on
line four
i'm doing that substring kind of uh
mapping on top of this value i'm
changing the value by
truncating it with a dot dot ellipsis if
it's too long
so i checked first to see if i have the
value that's what happens on line two
if it's a non-empty value and then i
check to see if it's
short and you know too long and then if
it is too long then i truncate it
and then we're going to do the exact
same thing but we're going to do it with
a maybe
so again you see that our our friend
maybe.from we
and then we call dot map after that
monad
so this is the functor nature of our
monads coming into play if you remember
that functor was
a thing that can be mapped over so we
have a dot map method on
our monad and the dot map method has
this interesting characteristic to it
that for a for a a monad that could have
these kind of these no ops like these
empty values
then map is basically not going to do
anything in the nothing case
it's a no up it's just going to skip
over it's short circuiting it's a little
bit like how promises
you know have promised.then over and
over again if you get an exception and a
promise
it's just going to skip right over all
of the other items in our promise chain
it's sort of the same thing so the map
call here is safe
it'll only run in the case of our our
monad
having a real value that we've matched
that we've gotten
for this description but it won't run in
the case where
we didn't have anything which is why we
can then do still call our fold call
and we didn't do our processing or kind
of string concatenate
shrinking or you know the ellipsis or we
didn't do that logic in the case of
the empty missing value we just kind of
skipped over the map call and went right
to the fold call so one last example of
using the maybe and this is a bit
different
but it's actually more common for maybe
to be illustrated in this way
if you've seen the relatively recent
javascript feature which is that
question mark
or the optional chaining operator as
it's referred to and it kind of
allows us to safely access properties in
objects
well if you were doing like you see here
on line nine we're doing the question
mark dot in question mark dot well
that's safe in case of
one of those properties being missing
like you see on line 12 we don't have a
thumbnail
and so of course that would fail but it
doesn't fail it just kind of gracefully
falls back to undefined it short
circuits out
to the undefined value so a lot of
people are really excited about this
kind of you know property access where
we don't have to do all the if then
checks which you're probably familiar
with
but i just wanted to show you that in
addition to doing this with nice new
syntax
this is a perfect example of a very
common
example of illustrating the maybe monet
so how would we do this if we were going
to do it with maybe
what we do is we we have that same entry
value but you notice that i'm going to
throw it into the
maybe with a maybe.from i'm going to
throw our entry in there
and then i'm going to do these chain
methods now you remember that chain is a
method that the monad laws require
the capability of they don't necessarily
require it to be called chain but we
have to have that capability
available to us since it's a monad we
can just call chain on it
and go to the next one and and chain has
that same short circuiting behavior that
we saw
in the previous slide with map if at any
point along the way
we failed to find that property if that
property access that we're doing
we have our property function that i've
kind of put there in comments on line 9
that prop function is doing maybe.from
and if that ends up with a maybe nothing
because the property was not there
well then all the rest of those chain
calls are skipped over because they're
no
ops and then we just fall to that last
one which is the inspect
so that's why the first time line 15 we
see the maybe just
with our url in it but then on line 22
we see just the maybe nothing
okay so that's another example and again
that's more verbose of course
but the power of having our may our our
values and our behaviors modeled as moan
ads
really begins uh begins to be unlocked
when we start putting more and more
monets together
because if you think about the maybe
nothing that we see
on line 22 that is not at all the same
thing as the undefined value that we see
on line 13.
they may seem like they're kind of one
and the same or that the maybe nothing
is
a lot of circumstance but not actually
any benefit because
the maybe nothing feels like a really
like do nothing kind of monad
but actually the maybe nothing is a lot
more useful
than just an undefined value we have to
put a lot of caveat checks around an
undefined value that passes through our
program
but if we have a maybe nothing and we
pass it around all our other monads
because of the way monads interact with
each other it'll safely interact in all
the no op ways that we expect
so we don't have to write all of that
special case condition
if statement kind of stuff
all right we said task two was how could
we gracefully handle exceptions
and here i'm going to introduce the
either monat the either moden
is a bit like maybe they're both kind of
what we would refer to as a sum
type meaning that they're kind of
keeping multiple values in this case two
values together
um and and and on in the either in in
the maybe we called it just and nothing
remember maybe was a pairing
of just or nothing depending on the kind
of emptiness of what value we put into
it
but with the either it we call it left
and right
and typically the either monad is
reserved or
it is often used to handle exceptions
somewhere in our code something happens
and we need to kind of
gracefully fall out of that exception
handling but we need to hold on to what
happens because
maybe we need to report that to a log or
maybe we need to edit to
we need whatever that value is to be
able to gracefully recover from it
and so the either monad is actually
allowing us
um to model the exception message we
typically would reserve the left side of
the either for the exception message
and the right side as whatever is next
you can just keep going
so it's going to have that same sort of
short circuiting behavior not that much
unlike a try catch
a try catch would sort of we could list
several operations in a try block and
whenever the first exception happens it
exits out and goes immediately to the
catch
it's kind of the same thing if you model
a bunch of operations
as chained onto an either at any point
if one of those
fails with an exception well then it
just sort of
you know bows out or short circuits out
to the either left value
and then it goes all the way down to the
end it doesn't any of the map calls or
chains that you do on it
will just be no ops so very similar to
maybe in that respect
all right so the left side might hold
an exception and we said try catches are
kind of an example of that so here's an
example in my code base
where i needed to parse some json and
then save that to a database
right very straightforward i have
parsing of json and the on line two and
then line three we're saving to the
database
and you've probably written code like
this before and try catches work just
fine
but usually for like one level if you
have like multiple levels deep it gets
really complex
and that's where maybe something like
the either monad might start to shine so
let's do this exact same example but
let's do it with the either mona
we're going to define this little helper
function that we call
safe here and the safe is going to try
to do some operation
and it's going to throw the success of
that operation into an either right as
you see there in line
three or on line four if it fails it's
going to throw that error message into
an either left
so when we call this parse function
we've defined parse line six
in terms of our safe that's a safe
wrapper around json parse
and on line eight when we call parse we
are we are
going to get back an either that will
either be in either left or on either
right
if it's on either left it's just going
to skip those next operations so we
won't do the chain
and we'll skip right to the fold if it's
an either right then we will do the
chain
which case we do the safe wrapper around
our save to db
function and then if that succeeds then
we end up with an either right which
on line 12 here will just fall into the
identity function
if either of those two steps failed we
end up with an either left and then we
fall
into the line 11 side of the fold
which just allows in this case it just
alerts our error message
okay so we see our friend foldable
coming back similar to how we did it
with maybe as we see foldable on
our either monad and that allows us to
kind of short circuit out there as well
all right our third task was the i o
monad
we're going to use the iomo now to
manage our i o
our side effects we have this io monad
that
is a bit different from the other ones
but it's more powerful
where the other ones were holding on to
things like numbers or strings or
whatever the i o monad
basically holds on to a function and it
tr because functions are first class
citizens that's a value just like the
number 42
is but because it's holding on to that
function it essentially treats the
behavior inside of that function
which would typically be side effects
things like our console log statement
for example
that's a side effect it would treat
those side effects as lazy
meaning they don't happen right now they
happen whenever
we tell the whole i o to happen which
actually happens
at the run call so you see line three a
dot run call
will trigger the whole chain of i o
operations
but as we chain everything together none
of it is actually happening
it's all just kind of lazily piling its
way up and then we have this whole
string of side effecting operations that
will occur
only when we invoke that run method so
in this example here i've got like a
hello to console the hello message
and i've got a world io that will
console log the world message
and then you'll notice lines eight and
nine i chain those together
i can do that because io's a monad and
we know that monads are going to give us
in in this implementation a chain method
so i can take the hello monad and chain
it to
the world monad and then i have this
composed i o monon that
expresses two different side effects the
console message of hello and the console
message of world
both being side effects and you know
side effects are anything whether it's
console messages or dom operations
binding event handlers making ajax calls
setting timeouts anything asynchronous
all of that it's all
side effects so i o actually becomes
really powerful because we can
model pretty much all those operations
with an with a
properly and powerfully implemented i o
monet
and some more on that in just a moment
but you can see that i've composed the
two together lines
8 and 9 and then on line 10 that's when
i invoke it so i can call.run
i'm doing it immediately here but i
don't have to do it immediately
i could express the composition of these
two side effects which
seems a little strange we wouldn't
normally think of being able to compose
two side effects since
composition generally only works with
pure non-side-effecting things
the power of the iomone out here is that
i've composed to
actual side effects together and and
that's still
okay because none of it's happened
because it's lazy and then later i could
decide
that i want to take that moan out and
either combine it with some other monad
or actually invoke it with the dot run
call
and i o is going to ensure that we have
a nice predictable sequencing of all
these side effects
and even if they're asynchronous
everything will compose the way that we
expect
so we can manage side effects in our
programs absolutely we can manage side
effects in our programs and many of you
have done that before
for example here's another here's
another piece of code from that app that
i was talking about
here i've got these functions first and
second on line six and ten
and those are actually creating side
effects because they're pulling
something off an array they're modifying
that global array
to pull off the first element and then
the next element off of that array
and i can manage those side effects
manually in this playlist function
line 15 i can take in 16 i can take
those two things and put them together
and i can make sure they happen in a
specific order and so you've probably
written code exactly like that playlist
function many many many times
and you're managing your side effects
very straightforwardly
but as soon as you start to compose that
with some other side effects and compose
those into bigger and bigger side
effects
things do start to get hairy as soon as
we have side effects all over the place
so one of the benefits one of the values
of being able to use the i o monad
is that we can compose all of these sort
of i o operations together all these
side effect operations together
so let's look at the exact same example
but let's do it with the iomo now
you'll notice i still have my entries
array and i'm still doing first
and second but lines eight and nine i
have first and second modeled as i o
operations
and then line 10 i start to set up my
playlist function but i'm going to set
it up as a monad
and an iomone ad rather than a regular
function and i'm going to define that
the operations are
first concatened with a comma in between
concated with
second there's concat again remember
concat was our
uh semi-group from before so we have our
semi group being repeated here we have
concatable
that behavior kind of helping it's one
of those friends that's come along with
the monad to help us
and concat is going to basically allow
an underlying value if it's able to be
concatenate
it's going to essentially kind of defer
to that to allow it to happen
so it's going to basic or you know
delegate down so we know that strings
can be compounded concatted
and that's exactly what's happening here
is that these these three strings in
these
three different iomo ads are all being
concatened together by virtue of that
concat method that's happening there
and then all of that is the monad and
then at some time whenever we want to we
can call playlist.run and all of those
operations happen in a nice predictable
order
and that or we could take that i o monad
called playlist here and we could
compose that with some other io modad or
some other monad entirely
to decide what we want to do in our
programs okay so again because io is
lazy none of that happened until the run
call
and that's why it gives us some more
predictability only we decide when we
invoke the run function
that we want our operations to start
creating our side effects
let's give a little bit more uh glimpse
specifically into moni
moneo's implementation of i o again not
as a sales pitch here but i want to give
you some
understanding of how moneo tries because
it the the main
idea behind manila was to have a really
powerful kind of uber
i o monad that could do everything with
all these helpers kind of all mixed in
with it and so the one of the things
that i really wanted was i wanted to
bridge the gap between the really
strictly functional world
where everything is a chain and
everything's kind of composed through
chaining and things
that's an unfamiliar style to us i
wanted to bridge that with
a style of coding that we're a little
bit more familiar with for example the
kind of async await syntax
and that's exactly what you see here by
way of this generator we have what in
the haskell world they call do syntax
but
the implementation here in javascript
uses a generator and we're using
generators so we use the yield instead
of the await
but under the covers is basically doing
what we expect in a weight to do is kind
of unwrapping this thing
here the yield keyword is chaining our
ios together
and so we get this syntax that looks a
lot more familiar to us
inside of a generator here it looks a
lot more like the async await style that
we're used to
and we can kind of reduce some of the
mental overhead of trying to switch
styles into the entirely kind of
functional chaining aspect that we might
be uh expecting so
i just wanted to call out that the
moneo's i o supports that do style
syntax with generators some libraries do
some libraries don't but this was kind
of the main one of the main motivating
factors
behind manil oh and by the way there are
lots of other things that the i o monad
can do
in moneo and i don't have time to get
into all of this but this is a quick
little example
and there's a link here to this is a
demo off of the mineo repo if you want
to go and
see this but i just wanted to quickly
call this out because you'll see that
that looks exactly like
async away syntax we're doing ajax calls
which you would almost certainly have
done in an async await function
we're using the yield keyword here
instead of the await keyword but under
the covers we're doing the exact same
thing
which is that we're chaining these
asynchronous ios together
so the thing i want to call out for you
is that moneo's i o does something kind
of special that most other ios don't
which is that it's a transparent
transformer over
native javascript promises which means
we can do both synchronous i o
operations and
asynchronous ones all together in the
same chain or inside the same do block
the same generator
it'll all work exactly the same whether
it's synchronous or asynchronous
because i wanted this to be more
ergonomic the way we would typically do
with our asynchronous programming okay
and so here's an example of that here's
another example
in our in that same demo where i'm
pulling you know i'm doing more i have
this do syntax we have a generator here
and i'm doing this yield cash dot get
that you see
and then i'm doing a yield num nums dot
fold
well what is nums nums is a maybe and
here we're doing a fold so
now i'm mixing a maybe together with an
iomone ad
and i'm i'm doing so inside of that do
style syntax so we have the ability to
bring in all of our monads together in
one
the i o monad is also a reader and
that's that allows us to hold on to
an environment like a side effect
environment as we carry through our
operations
so there's a whole lot more involved but
the takeaway here is that that's kind of
your one-stop shop if you want to start
playing with monads you might want to
look at manila's io
plus the other helper monads all right
so that was a whole bunch to throw at
you i know
that you're probably like your mind is
kind of swimming but just as a quick
summary
we have the the monad type interface
which describes kind of
what things ought to be able to do but
it's really the focus
that we've had for the whole second half
of our discussion today is the specific
implementation a concrete value in our
code monad values
a monad versus the monet a monad value
in our program that we can do something
with
and by the way this is not an all or
nothing proposition
this idea of using monads what i'm
trying to do is show that we can
actually little by little incrementally
improve our code base with functional
principles and with monads you have to
rewrite the whole thing using monads
you can write just a little piece of it
at a time and progressively grow
so i hope that maybe you'll give monad's
a try after i've excited you from this
talk
and check out manila if that's useful oh
and by the way while you're at it you
should probably also pick up some
regular expressions
thanks very much for listening to this
talk and i'll see you around the
internet